so you're nestled in the 1970s you're
the inventor of baby formula a
life-saving creation for babies who for
whatever reason can breastfeed from
their mothers but just helping moms who
can breastfeed isn't enough is such a
small segment of the population is such
a small customer base how are you ever
gonna make a fortune with that never
so you're looking to expand your formula
business even more instead of just
selling to moms who can't breastfeed
what if you could sell to every mother
if you could do that your customer base
will instantly increase by 20 to 100x
the problem is you've got some steep
competition mother nature's milk
something that is vastly superior and
has far more nutritional value for
infants compared to the glorified
powdered cow's milk mixed with sugar
that you're selling so you need a way to
fool the general public to dupe them
into thinking that formula is far better
than natural breast milk now you may be
saying to yourself but jake if we did
that wouldn't we be intentionally making
babies malnutritioned well
yes
so anyways you need to convince the
world that formula milk is a million
times better than breast milk which
means you need a little bit of
propaganda
paying doctors to peddle your formula
and the nestle campaign that was
concocted would turn into one of the
greatest medical scandals of the 20th
century from the biggest food company in
the world
[Music]
ever notice when you're making up some
quick
you stir until it's rich and thick
you hate to take that nice little sip
cause you know it'll be gone in a sip
it's so rich and thick and chocolate
that you can't
drink it
[Music]
that's the saddest sound i know
[Applause]
businesses like nestle have a credit
rating or a credit score just like you
and i do the better your credit score
the easier your life is you can rent a
place to live easier you can get a lower
interest rate so you're paying less when
you buy a house or a car etc the problem
is traditionally you'd have to get a
credit card to start building your
credits but in order to get a credit
card you need to have good credit but in
order to have good credit you need a
credit card do you see the problem here
you get stuck in this weird chicken and
egg loop where you need credit to build
credit that's where extra comes in
today's video sponsor extra is the
world's first ever debit card that
builds up your credit score and earns
rewards just like a real credit card you
heard that right a debit card that lets
you build up your credit score here is
how it works all you have to do is
connect extra to your existing bank
accounts extra will give you a spending
limit based on your balance with no
credit check you get your extra card in
the mail and then you swipe your extra
card for whatever you buy extra then
spots you for the purchase and then auto
pays themselves back the next business
day at the end of the month they report
all your purchases back to the credit
bureaus as creditworthy purchases
building your credit history an extra is
way better than getting a secured credit
card because there's no deposit required
you don't pay any interest or fees and
you earn reward points just like a real
credit card so if you're ready to start
spending smarter pause the video and
join the over 80 000 members building
their credit history with extra with the
link in the description below
[Music]
coffee doctor oh fine
i have a camel with your coffee thanks
you know
this night works kind of rough isn't it
that's right
but a camel's always a pleasure to
understand how we're gonna run our
propaganda campaign for baby formula
instead of starting from scratch all we
gotta do is take a lesson from some of
history's foremost experts at molding
public opinion cigarette companies
in a cigarette it's the tobacco that
counts and lucky strike means fine
tobacco see contrary to the symbol of
death and disease it is today once upon
a time in the early 1900s cigarettes
were a cultural icon of sophistication
glamour and sexual allure a highly
prized commodity for one out of every
two americans
and how did cigarette companies achieve
the symbol of sophistication with things
like full color magazine ads with
respectable looking doctors in white
coats puffing away with slogans like
more doctors smoke camels than any other
cigarettes an early example of an
influencer campaign
why because who do people look up to
when it comes to what they consume
doctors who do people look up to to
determine what's cool celebrities
we know with mathematical certainty that
large numbers of people will follow the
advice of their doctors because we
understand the psychological dependence
men have on their physicians so if our
goal is to get mothers to choose baby
formula over their own breast milk all
we gotta do is to get their doctors to
tell them to
so you start nestle's 1970s influencer
campaign to basically get doctors to say
formula good breast milk bad
you pay doctors and nurses to suggest
your formula as an alternative to breast
milk and in places like asia and africa
you even hire sales women dress them up
like nurses and get them to hand out
free samples and medical advice and you
make sure that these free samples are
just big enough that by the time they
run out these mothers would have stopped
making breast milk naturally cementing a
profitable loyal customer
who cares if africa one of your biggest
markets has polluted water who cares if
most of the moths using your formula
don't know that they need to boil the
water first to prevent the bacteria in
the water from making their baby sick
who cares if it's estimated that babies
who are fit formula and unhygienic
conditions are between 6 to 25 times
more likely to die of diarrhea and 4
times more likely to die from pneumonia
compared to breastfed babies
but that's not your fault obviously you
print the instructions on the package
and they're responsible for reading them
even if they're illiterate but then you
run into a problem powdered cow's milk
sugar and vegetable oil are even close
to real breast milk it contains none of
the stuff that can help babies fight off
diseases or build natural immunity it
doesn't even contain enough nutrients to
keep a baby healthy and in 1978's nestle
executives were even brought before the
u.s senate to explain why all these
babies were dying or getting sick
because of their formula milk would you
agree with me that your product should
not be used where there is
impure water
yes or no uh we give all the
instructions just just answer what would
you what is your favorite but we cannot
spoke with that
well as i understand what you say is
where there's impure water it should not
be used
yes where the people are so poor that
they're not going to realistically be
able to continue to purchase that and
which is going to mean that they're
going to dilute it to a point
which is going to endanger the health
that it should not be used yes i think
now then my final question is is what do
you do or what do you feel is your
corporate responsibility to find out
the extent
of the use of your product in those
circumstances in the developing part of
the world do you feel that you have any
responsibility we can't have that
responsibility sir may i make a
reference to
uh you can't have that responsibility no
no so by 1981 the world health
organization set new regulations where
you can no longer compare breast milk
with formula alternatives that is a
problem a problem that can be solved by
moving your marketing to somewhere with
fewer restrictions like southeast asia
and the pacific where formula sales are
skyrocketing while acting like you are
breast milk's biggest fan in the us and
europe even creating a cringy baby band
to get your point across
[Music]
and even after millions of people start
boycotting your products and stricter
laws are put in place to stop you from
tricking people into using your formula
there are still reports of nestle paying
their doctors to promote their products
giving out free samples and advertising
in hospitals
to this day i would almost argue you
should never give your child any formula
that you haven't run by your
pediatrician formula milk has around a
23 profit margin meaning companies like
nestle make around 23 cents for every
dollar in sales and by 2026 this
industry is set to be worth more than
110 billion dollars
but if you thought nestle stopped there
oh you're so sadly mistaken
[Music]
do
what is the number one thing humans need
to survive aside from food it's water
that's why the water business can be
very lucrative if done right see tap
water itself the stuff that comes out of
your sink is pretty inexpensive but
bottle up that tap water market is
coming from clear mountain springs or
majestic fountains and you have a
ridiculous markup you can buy a tank of
tap water for ten dollars use it to fill
thousands of plastic bottles and then
resell that tap water for fifty thousand
dollars for one tanker load nestle pays
ten dollars
once bottled the same water costs fifty
thousand dollars
and this is not an exaggeration by the
way nestle literally sold bottled tap
water with one of the recent lawsuits
dating back to as early as 2012 but just
like baby formula you can only get away
with so much in first world countries
it's third world countries where you can
really take it to an extreme in pakistan
in 2013 it was revealed that nestle was
diverting clean drinking water away from
villages and towns and then packaging it
in their factories they would then
resell that water back to the same
people they took it from honestly it's
pretty genius if you ask me the people
in these towns were forced to drink
dirty polluted water because they
couldn't afford to buy the bottled water
that was actually theirs to begin with
here is what the chairman of nestle had
to say about whether or not everyone
should have access to water yeah
extreme beauty songs
ngos
versa
[Music]
a decade later he clarifies his position
i have always supported the human right
to water everyone should have enough
clean safe water to meet their
fundamental daily needs but if you
thought nestle stopped there you are
still sadly mistaken
dad says he can pick his favorite
chocolate blindfolded was it that one
nope
try this one
yes that's it no mistaking it that's
nestle's chocolate the smoothest
creamiest chocolate of them all
try the blindfold test prove nestle's
best
[Music]
nestle baby formula bad nestle bottled
water bad but at least your candy is
okay right i mean what could be more
innocent than a kitkat wrong again
three million tons of chocolate is eaten
every year but have you ever wondered
where those cocoa crops come from well a
good chunk of it is grown in africa
including the ones used by nestle which
can involve a lot of child slavery and
forced labor
chocolate is one of the products nestle
is most famous for kitkat bar 1 and the
milky bar are all nestled chocolate bars
and let's face it coca is expensive you
have to bring it all the way from africa
which is already eating into your
profits so what do you do you tap into
the cheap labor market more specifically
you start buying coca beans from farms
that use forced child labor to harvest
the beans and it was all going according
to plan until the year 2000 when a
report came out that nestle cadbury and
mars were all guilty of buying blood
coca and that they knew about it all
along nestle promised to free his
chocolate candy from slave labor by 2005
and missed that deadline and all the
deadlines after that the excuse quote
the use of child labor in our coca
supply chain goes against everything we
stand for end quotes says nestle
executive vice president of operations
jose lopez quote no company sourcing
coca from the ivory coast can guarantee
that it doesn't happen but we can say
that tackling child labor is a top
priority for the company end quote which
obviously made people even angrier so to
placate the masses you collected all the
cocoa you can find from farms that don't
use child labor and make kitkat you slap
a fair trade label on it and it becomes
a symbol of a reformed caring nestle all
the while you still continue using dirty
coca for all your other candy and when
trends change from being morally correct
to being environmentally correct you
switch to a much cheaper alternative an
environmentally friendly label that
takes less effort money and resources
and diverts attention away from your
shady supply chain but if you thought
nestle stopped there you are yet again
sadly mistaken
[Music]
i see automation displaces labor in your
organization too dr sloan ah captain q
join me in a glass of delicious
chocolate quick well you
thank you doctor i could use some energy
[Music]
incidentally one of those torpedoes you
fired at me was circling and
you're sunk
thank you
some people will do anything to get rich
quick
[Music]
ethiopia is one of the poorest countries
in the world and in 2002 they were in
the middle of one of the worst famines
in history what does this have to do
with nestle well in 1986 nestle bought a
german company based in ethiopia that
had been nationalized in the 70s the
ethiopian government owned nestle money
and offered 1.5 million as compensation
but by 2002 due to a new exchange rate
this amount had become 6 million dollars
as nestle you could have written that
debt off pretty easily there were
millions of people starving in ethiopia
and 6 million could have went a long way
it could provide safe drinking water for
1.5 million families or anti-diarrhea
medicine for 750 000 kids but instead of
writing this debt off you demand your
money back even while you were making a
3.9 billion dollar profits if people
disliked nestle before they really hated
nestle now and by trying to get money
back from ethiopia you commit what would
be known as the greatest public
relations blunder of the decade nestle
eventually backed down due to mounting
pressure of boycotts but the damage to
their reputation have been done
today nestle is the biggest food company
in the world even after years of
controversial tactics to say the least
no one can deny that international need
for water formula milk and yes even
chocolate and they've done a pretty good
job of keeping their shady pass under
wraps so people are still buying
products from their almost 2 000
different brands
nestle operates in 190 countries employs
almost 300 000 people and has 376
factories worldwide nestle is one of the
best employers in europe and a
powerhouse of a food company a food
company where even nestle has admitted
that 60 of its products aren't even
healthy
[Music]
yes once again i kind of look like an
sjw it came out a little bit more purple
than i anticipated but i assure you that
it should fade out to a more natural
blonde if you're new here we make video
essays documentaries on the most
provocative stuff in the world of money
power war and crime so if you're not
already subscribed click that red button
below because you will not regret it if
you want more day in the life kind of
stuff you can follow me on instagram
jaytrend.io thanks for being part of the
watch the end club keep sharpening that
mind stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you